không cấp cho khu khí là mằng 2 rung sẽ dùa
có thể thích em phải đi tính công ra
bây giờ thì mài tói này
công ra được tính màn công thức
mà mà em em cho nên phải
cái này này rồi
là lực
nó khối khí xin là lạnh biết đâu
lực em
biết tông chuyển là
mình xong bên phải
như bệnh từ vận nó về là
đem thầy mài tói này người ta cho biết
lực mà sát vılc tông và xí này
em mà sát đấy
lực em mà sát
có đông này chuyển nó thẳng nèu
cho nên cái lực em
bằng với lực em mà sát
tà thái cái lực em mà sát
em mà sát
bức tông dịch chuyển
đi được quan được nằm sẵn đi mẹp
bài
tà đau biết
nằm sẵn đi mẹp
rồi
tí tiao
lực ăn phà
lực ăn phà là lực không thể
dưới quách đơn lực tăng dụ
nó được em
bởi phương chuyển đâu
như vậy
bởi phương chuyển nó
bởi phương chuyển
vầy
lực
ăn phà là xe ăn mằng không được
em thấy số bà
lực bằng mò
vầy em bính là được
công a là mằng mò dù
nếu các em không biết mà các em thấy
mẹp dương
cậm với nè cuy mằng hai mà đây
nè bằng bà
xa hai màn thóa lột
bây giờ đây là gì
khối khi nè
xinh cộn
ở công a đó
ăn
của hí xinh cộn thì công a
bây giờ thì mình là khí
tập những lấy tông
thì cái công a này
nó phải nè ăn mò
còn khu khi là dất dụng
thì quý dụng
cộn 2
bây bằng bò
rù
xong rồi bây bài phó ăn được ra
ok